wendy williams has tested positive for
kobit 19 and is postponing the season 13
premiere of the wendy williams show
i said what
what on tuesday the popular daytime talk
show announced that the 57 year old tv
personality is postponing the new season
of her show in order to quarantine and
get better no regrets season 13 of the
wendy williams show was scheduled to
start on september 20th the date has now
been moved to october 4th a statement
posted to the show's official instagram
account explained that in the meantime
reruns will be scheduled to air
last week fans grew concerned after the
show announced that wendy was dealing
with ongoing health issues and was
undergoing further evaluation and
therefore would not be able to complete
her promotional appearances for season
13. it's been a long summer and we've
got a lot to talk about back in january
wendy appeared on the dr oz show and
said she didn't want to get the coven 19
vaccine no
no
no i don't trust it i've never gotten
the flu shot either though and you and i
have talked about that and several of
the doctors on my team talk to me about
wendy we'll get the flu shot
i've never had the flu i'm not getting a
flu shot i very rarely get a cold i
never have headaches
i don't take an aspirin because i feel
my heart murmur or something like that
i'm not getting no i don't trust it
there i said it but this isn't the first
time wendy has taken time off of her
show due to health issues back in may
2020 she announced she would be taking a
step back to deal with health concerns
related to graves disease and in
february 2018 shortly after revealing
her diagnosis wendy told viewers she
needed a break to handle her illness my
thyroid my hyperthyroid is attached also
to
graves disease
graves disease
squeezes the muscles behind your
eyeballs i feel like they're birds
swimming around my head you know like a
cartoon
like
constantly high
but not high
and when she came back in march she
opened up to dr oz about taking the time
off i had to take three weeks off of
work which was horrible
but needed